bonjour je m'appelle Alexandre paviel
j'ai 22 ans j'habite au port je suis à
la recherche d'un métier graphiste
infographiste mes études ont été le bac
pro d'artisan et métier d'art option
communication graphique et le cap de
Dessinateur d'exécution en communication
graphique situé au lycée professionnel
de
Saint-Pierre mes qualités sont motivées
dynamiqu créatif autonome et
consciencieuse j'ai fait des stages au
niveau de des services communication au
service graphi
infographique j'ai été mis sur des
maquettes création logo
maquetis j'ai effectué des expositions
au Service
Scolarité basé sur les Terres australes
et Antarctique française et service
Colonia ma passion c'est plus la
photographie F la ceultureur l'origami
n'hésitez pas à me contacter si ma
candidature vous a plu